[Music]
some kids have extraordinary conditions
some have unbelievable abilities some
are changing the world and they're all
amazing learn more about 10 amazing kids
you won't believe actually exist and if
you're new to our channel hit the
subscribe button down below
kang kang now who came who is
affectionately known as kang kang was
job to mask boy by the media because of
a rare birth defect he was born in China
in 2009 with a transverse facial cleft
this makes him look like he has two
faces he underwent surgery in 2010
thanks to money donated to him by the
public doctors predict they'll have to
wait 10 years to see the results of the
operations Julia Marie Arana most people
don't read 1000 books in their lifetime
but Julia Marie Arana achieved that feat
by the tender age of 4
her parents read to her from birth and
realized she could recognize the words
at just 18 months she signed up for the
Georgia 1000 books before kindergarten
program at two-and-a-half and the child
prodigy completed it by an age when most
kids can't even read at all the bookworm
visited the Library of Congress could be
their librarian for the day in 2017 now
named Sam Lang was dubbed a hobbit boy
by his classmates because the Chinese
teenager was born with a genetic
condition that made his feet swell they
became so abnormally large he couldn't
even wear shoes
his parents were too poor to pay for
treatment so his feet grew larger and
larger finally at the age of 14
Zhou had an operation for free at
Shanghai Children's Hospital thanks to
his teacher's campaign the doctors
pioneering for our surgery was
successful Ryan Hale Jack Ryan Hale Jack
was a pretty remarkable six-year-old in
grade 1 the Canadian learned people were
dying because they didn't have clean
water after a year of fundraising he
spent $2,000 to water can to drill a
well and Uganda in two years he raised
61 thousand dollars and appeared on The
Oprah Winfrey Show then aged just ten he
established the Ryan's well foundation
in 2001 by 2017
I already had brought water to 1,000
communities in 16 countries helping 890
2725 people panjang hyung panda Hans
neighbor called him fish boy because his
body is covered in six kills the Chinese
boy was born with a rare genetic skin
disease ichthyosis it's named after the
ancient Greek word for fish hand suffer
severely with the condition the scales
limit the movement of his legs and arms
and even affect the shape of his ears
mouth eyes and nose there is no known
cure for the dry scaly skin the only
treatment is moisturizers to try to
lessen the pain and Donna unnie cushions
non Donna Anna Krishna's parents first
noticed her amazing ability when she was
9 the girl from India was able to read
her mother's mind they believed she was
telepathic and could feel her mother's
emotions and know what she was thinking
she even developed the ability to know
what food her mother was going to make
her a one-and-a-half she was diagnosed
as a highly functioning child with
autistic spectrum disorder and attention
deficit hyperactivity syndrome
Jacksonville's doctors predicted Jackson
Bo would never smile or speak nor would
he reach his second birthday Jackson
school is half locked which prevented
part of his brain from forming but the
boy from Florida born with micro hygiene
and Cecily
proved them wrong he smiles when he
hears his name and she turned two and a
half in February 2017
he became an internet sensation in 2015
when a faceless photo of Jackson and
father Christmas went viral
his parents share Facebook updates about
his milestones like reaching his hands
up and following conversations to sandal
and kiss and Ellen wasn't your typical
10 year old when she learned about
fossil fuel damage in fifth grade she
decided to take action with her friends
she set up a project called turn grease
into fuel TGIF took used cooking oil
from restaurants in Cassandra's hometown
of Westerly Rhode Island and turned it
into biodiesel this has been used to
warm the homes of over 500 families in
TGIF is now donated over 50,000 gallons
of bio heat to seven local charities
Charlie Parker most adults wouldn't want
to go near a crocodile the little
Charlie Parker is a brave boy he's known
as the world's youngest Crocodile Hunter
the Australian taught first wrestled a
crocodile when he was three and he first
held a snake when he was one these
antics have earned him the nickname mini
Steve Irwin shall be loves to help his
parents run the Ballarat Wildlife Park
after school we feed the animals and
helps them with live shows wearing his
own uniform real-live Benjamin Button a
baby born in Bangladesh September 2016
stunning doctors with his appearance the
newborn resembled in the elderly man
with his excessive wrinkles sunken eyes
and shrunken body
he suffered from progeria the rare
condition that causes a child's body to
age fast which is why the baby has given
the monitor the real-life Benjamin
Button rather than being obsessed his
parents this logic and Powell patro
talks of their happiness at the arrival
of their miracle son wicked beaten kids
amaze you the most let us know in the
comments and give us a big thumbs up
[Music]